boy you sure won that story okay thank
you for tuning in to the legends of
comedy that was fantastic you did a
great job they were loving Hardin
hitting questions in there well you
wrote them you wrote all of them can I
ask you something off the record
absolutely why do you have an intern
interview about your friends
you gotta pay your taxes everybody
the reality is oil is sold in dollars
globally right and that's what keeps our
currency having purchasing power people
complain about wars but that's the only
thing that maintains our way of life you
know cool cool cool Congrats man
listen I gotta grab a new drink
relax it's not like it's coming out of
your pocket
hey Errol you made it yeah just got here
well I'm glad you're feeling Oh David
how you doing my man I'd shake but I got
my hands full with $20.00 bourbon and
hot babe ass write that she's mad
because I won't buy her a drink what are
you working on I'm thinking of launching
a Twitter parody account fine
whoo well you know that's all right man
it takes time for some people I mean
look at Judge Judy say be seven years
old got the number one show on TV two
hundo mil Dolores and all she does is
decide who pays the electric bill that
could be you yeah you're right yeah I'm
wearing a thousand Oh sue you wearing a
performance fleece you don't to tell me
I'm right I know I'm right right babe I
don't think she speaks English
give her your a Stevie Wonder yeah would
you believe that that guy never learned
how to read music
that's impressive yeah I know I only say
things that are impressive I'm gonna go
talk to somebody over here
good time same time next week no I got
another Craigslist job it's a little
more dignified what is it
nude house cleaner I tell you nothing's
easy
you